hey youtubers is Charlie this week for
my Game of Thrones bonus video I'm gonna
talk about grumpy old man hating Game of
Thrones starting with Stannis I'll say
right off the bat Stephen Delana is an
amazing actor but the number of grumpy
old men complaining about how they don't
understand Game of Thrones and they
don't understand why everyone is so
crazy about it has risen 200 percent in
the last couple of months it's crazy I
cannot wait till Game of Thrones ends
its run so we can hear what all of the
actors want to think about it the
problem with that is that most young
actors are still looking for work and if
they get paid a lot of money by HBO they
don't want to burn that bridge people
like Stephen tulane ian mcshane they're
really old they have tons of money it's
not like they have to keep working so
it's a lot easier for them to just speak
their mind grumpy old men style so let's
talk about Stannis Baratheon just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far I'm
gonna explain a little bit about what he
said what the actor said in real life
and what that means for the show
compared to the books and there is a new
round of the DVD giveaway it's a copy of
the season 5 DVD all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll explain a
little bit more at the end of the video
so here we go Stannis Baratheon what the
hell just happened well Stephen Delaine
did his ian mcshane style interview
where he just spoke his mind about the
show just a paraphrase he said things
like I didn't understand the show when I
was on it I don't understand why it's so
popular I didn't really even enjoy it
that much I just liked the money things
like he did it just because it was
another job like a lot of old-school
actors there a lot of older actors that
are from an era where you know studio
contracts used to be a bigger thing and
they would just do the next job they
wouldn't pursue as many passion projects
this is a job I earn money to support my
family I'm gonna go work the next job
after this job is done and there's
absolutely nothing wrong with that
people have to earn money to support
their families but it's just funny
because everyone is so hype about Game
of Thrones there will probably be an
actual cult surrounding the material the
books in the show before it's all over
and then in the back of your mind you
kind of wonder what's going on behind
the scenes when stuff like this happens
where like the producers and HBO's eyes
collectively roll into the backs of
their heads like oh jesus here we go but
in a practical sense his comments are
really like the straw that broke the
camel's back improving that Stannis
really did die he was killed by Brienne
the books he's still alive he's
preparing for an assault on Winterfell
just like he did on the TV show they
just sped that storyline up on the TV
show and it might not necessarily go
down the same way in the books George
our Martin tweaks things as he goes
along if you do really love the Stannis
character and you want him to still be
alive he is still alive in the books so
don't worry when winds of winter gets
here you get all the Santis you want on
the TV show now that he's dead there's a
few questions one what happens to his
meager holdings like storm's end like
what what happens to the things that are
left to hospira at the end he was in
super debt to the iron bank and then to
what is going to happen with winter felt
because Stannis was trying to get rid of
the Bolton's
well the season 6 trailer kind of
addresses that second question but the
first one is actually a pretty
interesting one a lot of you have asked
me now that Stannis is dead
all his children are dead what happens
to storms end
well one let's just assume that the iron
bank doesn't try to seize it as
collateral for the loans that it gave to
Santis let's just assume that they call
that a wash and they're gonna back
Daenerys because they feel like she will
win the throne and then she will repay
all the money that they are owed right
off the bat that unless it's proven in a
court of law that Tommen is not Robert's
son Tommen would officially inherit
storms end so until further notice it's
officially in the hands of the
Lannisters but there are a couple other
legit candidates including Gendry
technically if Gendry were to show up at
King's Landing and say I am Robert's
heir and he could prove it then he could
inherit storms and Cersei would probably
have his head chopped off before he had
a chance to get a word out because
technically he is a more legitimate heir
to the Iron Throne than Tommen because
Tommen has zero Baratheon blood so the
minute gand resurfaces he's dead so he's
not going to inherit storm's end as long
as the TV show keeps him in that rowboat
or keep Cersei in the red cape which i
think is gonna be through the duration
of season 6 moving down the list there
are a couple more choices one is through
Stannis's uncle lord esther mont who's
only in the books he's not on the TV
show as far as we know you could also
say that erin Florent of house Florent
has a legit claim because he's the
brother of Stannis's wife that he is a
book only character and the other is
actually a TV show character Daenerys is
the next legitimate heir to storms end
unless you just want to assume R plus L
equals J Jon Snow's
targaryen he has a blood link to house
baratheon Daenerys is just a little more
legit because she in that scenario would
be John's aunt
remember Rhaegar was Daenerys his older
brother John snow would be Rhaegar son
so she is his aunt so if a Targaryen
were to inherit storms and Daenerys
would do it before John snow but I don't
think either of them would inherit it on
the TV show because Tommen is still King
Cersei still considers herself Queen or
at least ruling his Queen Regent with
the help of zombie Mountain there is no
way that she would hand storms end to
one of her enemies if she had the chance
so what'll probably happen on the TV
show is they'll just keep it in the
hands of the Lannisters and longshot
Cersei might use it as a reward for
something like do this for me and I will
give you storm's end so if she wanted
via Tommen she could just dangle it in
front of anyone she wanted to get a
giant favor from but I just think it's
so cool that House Targaryen has been so
intertwined with house Baratheon across
the years Oris Baratheon first of
was best friends with Aegon the
conquerer so you know things change over
time they become mortal enemies Robert
Baratheon kills Rhaegar Targaryen you
get the idea alliances change across the
years but there are a number of people
who actually have legitimate claims to
storms end considering that Tommen does
not have a legit claim let me know in
the comments though what do you think is
going to happen with storm's end on the
TV show and what do you think is gonna
happen with it in the books don't worry
if you haven't read the books there are
just a lot more characters in the books
than there are in the TV show what's
gonna happen next is there's a new
Walking Dead video that I'm going to
post tonight there should be some new
Game of Thrones promotional material
either a new teaser or just like
something interesting from HBO around
season six in the next week or so if
they do drop something I'll totally make
a video for it what's gonna happen with
the giveaway is is because I don't know
if there's gonna be a new teaser
something in the next couple of days
I'll announce the winner in the next
game of Thrones video that I post well
you guys wait for my next video you can
click here to watch the red band trailer
again and you can click here to watch
the behind-the-scenes teaser which is
actually just as interesting as the red
band trailer so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you